what's up everybody this is a little
update video before the episode today I
just want to say we're here at Santa
Monica Music Center right now the
windows are literally boarded up we got
a little makeshift studio going on here
right now cuz Annie's the man and
figured out how to set it up and I just
want to say thank you thank you to every
single person thank you for the
donations the message is to support the
love everybody that has supported me
somehow thank you very much and lana
supports the cause as well and thanks
you guys as well and you really stepped
up and I just I'm speaking from the
heart right now so I might be stumbling
around but I come overwhelmed by the
love and the kindness so thank you night
pants nation strong I appreciate all
appreciate you all out there I do want
to let you know that we're gonna sell a
shirt it's up on the website now honey
do strong all proceeds will go to
benefit Santa Monica Music Center and
you're about to see this episode here
and then we've got two more already from
the studio that we'll be able to bring
and I did three honey-do with y'all's so
I've got two more of those so in the
meantime hopefully we can get some
windows put in here and get the place
back to normal and get back in here and
recording for you but that's what's
going on not gonna let you down we'll
figure it out somehow we're gonna do it
and we're gonna do it right and we're
gonna do it well like we always do it
thank you for your support I love you
guys enjoy this episode this episode of
the honeydew is brought to you by Omax
cryofreeze and blue chew more on that
later
let's get into the do you're watching
the honeydew with Ryan Sickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it at the honeydew
studios I'm Ryan Sickler the website is
Ryan Sickler com make sure you subscribe
to the email list there youtube.com
slash our Sickler is the link for
youtube if you're listening and you
haven't subscribed to the YouTube
channel to watch go do it now go
subscribe make sure you're also follow
me on Facebook on the Facebook fan page
and thank you guys for sending in your
honeydew stories man it's been really
fun to go through these and talk to some
of you guys the patreon show is called
the honeydew with y'all where we sit
down and highlight the lowlights with
y'all so please if you think you have a
story that should be heard or you know
someone you're like you got to go tell
Sickler this [ __ ] story have them
email me honey do podcast at gmail.com
honey do podcast com is the website you
can go get your merch get your night
pants I can't thank you again enough
night pants nation y'all it's growing
and growing night pants nation I see you
out there night pants in the daytime and
I want to give a special shout-out to my
friend Lana and agretti and the Santa
Monica Music Center where I record here
look if you live in LA and you need
lessons for your kids or you just want
them for yourself this is the spot
I'm telling you they've been here for 50
years they're a family-owned business
you know and I love that they serve the
community I'm so glad that that my money
goes toward a business that serves the
community and not just some you know
real estate mobile you know and with all
the uncertainty that with not being able
to come in and get in person and do
lessons they've really taken to the
online lesson so you know you live
anywhere in the world and you could
still get your kids or yourself
lessons from local Los Angeles musicians
so go to Santa Monica music calm and use
code honeydew and they will waive the
registration fee and give you one free
lesson when you sign up for a package
alright there's also a phone number on
on the website feel free to call them if
you have questions they have human
beings you believe it standing there
ready to answer your calls and
take care of you guys and over here we
highlight the low lights and I always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers and I can't wait to
introduce this next guest here man this
this is he is a true honey do y'all
he's also the Pro Bowl right tackle who
helps open lanes for Lamar Jackson of
the Baltimore Ravens the reigning NFL
MVP he's also the right tackle who
happens to block on the greatest rushing
team in the history of the NFL ladies
and gentlemen please welcome our Lando
Brown jr. y'all oh man my only regret is
we can't do this in person but I'm so
glad to have you on the show I'm stoked
to have look dude I got a Ravens hoodie
and look I got a Ravens t-shirt on it um
oh dude now I'm I'm gonna let everybody
know what we are you have such an
amazing story this is not going to be a
episode I know a lot of people but your
story needs to be told it needs to be
heard it's amazing but speaking of
amazing just tell me come on how great
was last season I mean you all meet you
oh you look great
you're the greatest rushing team in the
history of the league in your second
year yeah first things first presents
from me on I need to say thank you for
having me all but that's it last year
man it was just it was it was unreal
amount of fun that we had um I mean well
I can take you all the way back to OTS
and just how competitive practice was
then like as we getting ready to
transition into that that phase of mini
camp and then we get that Breaking and
we come back and we hit the ground
running as a team in the preseason then
you know we practice against
Jacksonville practice against Philly
Lamar Sean out you know what I mean all
of the top players are ignore really
well against other crops Herman and said
well we hit week one and I mean
Hollywood is going crazy not me I
obviously had those big catches and
- excellent for Mike 67-yard and I
remember after he caught it he's running
dog food I looked at Marshall Yaga to my
left I just look at him he goes [ __ ]
fast all he does his chest his nose it's
incredible
I'm so excited it was an amazing season
and you made Ledet legit history that's
not like you know he's made seven field
goals and from fifty I'm which is also
amazing but this is the greatest rushing
team in the history of the NFL that's
nuts to me dude you know and so it goes
back to like we met at Maryland live we
met when I was on the road with Tom and
Tom had hit me up before we were coming
I was like yo Orlando Browns coming to
the show and I was like Zeus is coming
to the show I was so [ __ ] stuck dude
cuz I look I've been a huge fan of yours
I've been following you I look I read I
go what the Ravens the whole year I'm
reading about the OTAs and who I know
everything going on right now with the
team that that they let you know that
they let you know I was so stoked to
meet you and Tom had showed me the girl
you were dating at the time and I was
like man she's fine she's fine so we get
we get to the show and the funny thing a
couple things happened so I started
talking there's two older black guys
that did security for us and they're
always my favorite guys they're always
my favorite guys and one of the guys I'm
telling him you know I'm well I'm from
here I'm just you know I live in LA now
but I'm from here and and we started
talking about work and [ __ ] and I go I
worked at UPS for a while by the way
shout out the UPS Baltimore hub primary
one Joe Avenue and he knew one of the
guys I knew and we're sitting there
talking about that I couldn't get old
I'm like god it's good to be back home
so then the main security guy this dude
was on point he didn't miss a detail so
he we were waiting we kept asking like
he's here yet is he here yet and then he
came back at one point is like Orlando's
here now and Tom goes man
did you see the girl he's with and I'm
telling you like like it was like this
was a movie with a scripted line was so
[Music]
[Laughter]
funny Dave so funny and then also I want
to say thank you for setting us up at
the Rams game out here because you took
care of us you got tickets for me my
stepson Derek Tom and we were out there
and um we took a couple pics so we took
a pic together when I met you at la lai
or Maryland live which we'll get into
and but we took one the stylet said Tom
like let's just take a photo of us
together and we were sitting next to
Hollywood Brown's grandma and she
straight-up [ __ ] photo bombed our
picture and I sent it to you I was like
look at Hollywood brows grab over here I
thought she was almost smiled up at our
picture but we met you after the show
and I want you to know this
you're just so you know your autograph
mini helmet is in our office in the
studio over here and the picture that
you took with Derek and me that is also
framed in the office brother I'm telling
you yeah you're the [ __ ] I love you man
you're you're just a great dude and
you're and under you've been an underdog
your whole [ __ ] life I know you have
and I root for the [ __ ]
underdog so let's talk about this well I
got wrote some stuff and wanted to talk
to you well real quick actually if you
could tell us what what are you hearing
about the season are you guys gonna have
we're gonna have some football with no
fans what's gonna happen it's really
hard to say you know I've heard a
variety of different things man I've
heard [ __ ] you're only gonna do half the
stadium so if a stadium holds 80 you're
only gonna let 40 years so 40
thousand titties you know I've heard
that regular season may get push back a
little bit you know if that second wave
does hit you know towards the end of
camp as far as I do know though I'm
pretty sure we're gonna start training
camp on time but there hasn't been
talked too much about training camp
necessarily now starting on time
now whether something happens and we
break from there but as far as I know
everybody but pretty much has a mindset
on coming back to lots of music spots on
so good man we need it this this we need
sports right now we need some men people
going crazy at home right now crazy body
oh [ __ ] that's what I do for a living I
know it totally mechanism for me so I
want to for a lot of people even the
casual sports fan I want to remind them
who your father was your Orlando Brown
jr. your dad was also Zeus as well I
love that you carried over the nickname
my dad's nickname was lefty I tattooed
that [ __ ] on my right arm but your dad
was on the unfortunate and a lot of
people if you're a casual sports fan
might remember your dad was on the
unfortunate of a penalty flag that was
thrown and it went in his facemask and
it blinded him just at the time he was a
Cleveland Brown that came to Baltimore
went back to Cleveland got the flag in
the eye and then was out of the league
for I think almost three years right
about that Yeah right
it was for my Oh mm like 2002 was when
he was out he first season back was like
oh three and like that spring oh three
bunny named back with the Ravens yep
yeah came back so from the things I've
read you know he came back he played I
guess he he didn't have full vision but
he was no longer legally blind is that
right it was yeah exactly so now details
on that man it's super Wishard so like
originally when it happened and I
by towards the December night of 99 I
remember like because I was actually at
that game I'm three years old you swear
to I remember at math left that I wanted
a like he already were I was three years
old so we always had a box like whenever
he played like he always had the box so
as far as I can remember whenever I went
to a football game
I was never necessarily the stands
always in defending boxing I remember
two gay men because everybody liked when
I was just at that age I'm like the
games I'm not necessarily playing paying
attention to ball I'm Pam stomping go
red light green light tag you're eating
crab cakes but I remember we were
playing around and everybody family room
just went completely quiet and like I
remember my mom who's there and she's
like what is going on why did he do that
why'd he do that and before you know it
like they're showing the replays on the
screen and then my dad's we're in a back
out of a field you did my you know and
Willis up frustrated for my dad is my
grandfather got diagnosed with our home
in 1993 he completely was blind and he
lost his eyesight so like my dad's eyes
were something like he really really
really took serious and my PTSD you know
it's unfortunate that really is man and
but but what a [ __ ] I just saw the
the NFL Films piece on your dad where
I've never seen there's two people they
happen to both be Ravens I've never seen
Bill Belichick just he loved her dad I
mean have you seen that piece you've had
have seen the piece where he talks about
getting him a suit and I mean what a
great story and you could really he was
emotional to telling that story he
really really cared for your dad it
seems like yeah check man he's somebody
that's he's been a positive impact in my
life since I even a little bit before
even since I lost my dad at 15 you know
I'm still staying in contact with him I
stayed in contact with Ozzy bro you know
from that point in telling my high
school but man coach Billy said man you
know I remember when I was coming out in
2018 for address now I kid you not we
probably talked for about a hour and 30
minutes men at the combine me and him
one on one man just talking ball it's
about 10:30 11 o'clock at night and man
I mean he's just an amazing person you
know the relationship that he had with
my dad was so special because believe it
or not like my dad grew up in inner-city
DC in the 80s you know and it's late in
the Latin 70s and my grandparents are
from South Carolina and like Augusta
Georgia so but they not say he was a
familiar white because he felt like he'd
better white meant that he could trust
yeah you know based on this cultural
background like restore background
how about was this home of everything
going on right now still yes yes and
that's you know and that's real life and
you know thank God for people like Bill
Bell it's a you know people like you you
know that they understand you know the
unfortunate events that a lot of black
men in America have to deal with and why
it makes them the way that it makes them
you know and I was fortunate enough man
- you know my dad exposed me to those
days in DC [ __ ] I grew up cleaning the
barber shops in DC Northeast busy
cleaning up Marvin Gaye apartment so
that's what I did in summers and you
know he exposed me to all that different
types of stuff and those different type
of people so you know I was fortunate
enough to not necessarily have to grow
around it but understanding well I
really want to get into your story
because you have such a fascinating
story I mean you're a Maryland kid who I
mean you grew up on the Ravens sidelines
and and they draft you and and you end
up playing your dad's position wearing
his number and don't they have some
equipment they've still had and
do you wear some of your dad's equipment
yeah I will so like I always wore like a
bandanna like a college and stuff and I
wore it a little bit my Ricky here they
won't let me wear all Sundays just
because a new era rule but yeah man
always always I love it dude and then
you get drafted by the team you grew up
on the [ __ ] sidelines for and now
play your dad's position come on so
we're at we're at Maryland live and
again the funny thing too that that I
forget about you is that how old are you
21 essentially four I mean you just
turned 24 you're 6 what 8 not yeah when
I look at a man your size the the the
age I bet you've probably dealt with
this in your life you look like you know
what I mean like you you feel older than
me when I look my neck has tilt up the
look
you know you sir you know what I'm
saying 23 years old you I want to call
you sir I I was I was so stoked to meet
you and I didn't want to bother you I
never want to bother people you know and
I didn't want to say anything to you in
the whole time I'm standing next to you
and I just it's just funny but I just
want to be like and you were so clearly
can we take a picture can I take the
problems like can I take a picture with
you you know what I mean like Jesus
Christ and then I was like dude can I
please just say something to you like
yeah go I'm sorry but I gotta say this
like you you're a Maryland [ __ ] kid
who grows up on the Ravens sidelines and
your dad tragically passes and then you
get passed over in the [ __ ] draft and
then the Ravens swoop in because they
know you and they know your character
and your hustle and they know they got a
steal and boom you come over and now you
really got something to prove because
your dad's legacy is on the line there
too and you know you're gonna [ __ ]
step up with not that you wouldn't have
done that for any other [ __ ] team in
the NFL but there's an extra edge when
the Baltimore Ravens come knocking
because it's Ozzy and you know Ozzy and
now you play as position you wear his
number you're a [ __ ] Pro Bowler and
you're on the greatest rushing team in
the history of the goddamn NFL it is
it's storybook [ __ ] it's you know it's a
Cal Ripken type story you know you're oh
you're that
that Maryland athlete's men you're the
athlete and by the way I cannot stop
staring at the San Fran Sun shirts and
I'll let you know I love we talked about
it before you how pleased I would love
for you to walk us chronologically
through your story yeah no no message
board 1996 to Hopkins Hospital Baltimore
Maryland um you know from there that was
the first year that the Ravens were in
Baltimore you know coming from because
they set down a franchise in Cleveland
then in 98 they reopened up the
Cleveland Browns so they gave some of
those guys that were originally on that
Cleveland team that moved to Baltimore
they gave them opportunities to move
back to Cleveland with the restart of
the franchise there in Cleveland so my
dad was one of those guys and so we
moved back to Cleveland in 1999 I had
another brother I was born in 97 in
Baltimore and another brother that was
born in 2000 in Cleveland my mom is
originally from Cleveland so that's
where my parents met actually met at a
club called the Mirage I don't know if
any of your listeners but they met at a
club called the more eyes I guess my dad
stole his nickname Roberson city that's
2000 men my parents they are the exits
pit split split up in 2001 on the
divorce wasn't fun to like Oh 607 my dad
played ball from finished up his career
from like Oh 307 and you know from there
man I you know I always wanted to play
ball football something I always wanted
to do but my dad wouldn't let me but he
was just very adamant on look pay
attention to school do like become a
doctor be a lawyer leave his football
[ __ ] alone epic ole it's too hard you
know and and so he spent a lot of time
like as a kid I remember in second grade
not a lot of people know this but a
second grade my mom signed me up for
Luther voters and so like I'm playing
literally Bob I'm in second grade I'm
playing with the [ __ ] 8th graders
seventh grades because of my weight
driving said you're playing with it so
at the time my dad was still in the lead
and come to find out my mom did it
behind my dad's back so I would only
play every other game so like you know
man my lesson was against the Redskins
[Laughter]
man he calls my mom snap she calls the
you gets the Luther coach's number he
snaps I text my dad I'm like we cannot
go return my years like not a worry
buddy I'll just give them a check for
keep that [ __ ]
so that year some we're not actually
worth on 0 that's early on in life like
around you know 2002 2002 or whatever
you know from there getting older I
really like from there from that point
on I didn't play organized football
again till like seventh grade well and
any other sports were you playing
baseball or basketball or anything else
I wasn't doing [ __ ] but I was in the AC
playing video games and eating cereal
that doesn't say we had gamer oh yeah
and yeah man so by the time an eighth
grade rolls around I'm 66 450 pounds and
we're a sucker 8th grade or 8th grade 6
6 450 in eighth grade 450 pounds man I
don't know why the hell my parents let
me get that big guys know a guy like I
know it sounds unbelievable I have to
see you a picture of me and one of my
closest friends bro you gonna last
please email we'll put it in this if you
give it to us in time for sure you're
powering over every teacher everyone
everyone oh yes man and you know
something that even at a young age you
know [ __ ] I'm in kindergarten the same
height as a fifth graders you know what
I mean it's like you know I'm so fast
and and I just kept growing you know I
even I could have two-inch in college
you know they do really so yeah I came
into college at like what was it I think
it was something weird like like six six
and six six and three-quarters or some
[ __ ] like that and my final measurement
said that combine was six seven and
three-quarters but wow this 684 yeah but
eighth grade man believe it or not then
I called my dad like went into that year
and at the time my parents had joint
custody so in the state of Maryland you
can't like pick who you want to live
with to you're 13 years old so we have
went through the summer like in the
summer times with my mom and dad and me
and my two brothers it was four weeks
with my own four weeks with that and so
literally dog I remember like I'm riding
home my mom from Florida and we were
standing my grandmother's driving back
up to Baltimore and then I was just
thinking to myself man guys I want to be
an NFL someday and you know I feel like
it was in that moment you know when I
got back I got with my dad I told my dad
now I said dad I want to play football I
want to be an NFL and you know the thing
that he told me was he said look I'll
let you play all I asked is that you
don't stop doing this [ __ ] to you ten
years in and you a Hall of Famer I was
like 10 years in like an NFL or ladies
like 10 years in NFL you [ __ ] I'm all
the favor that's what you can stop doing
this [ __ ] and I'll be like okay anything
before that is not accepted well I'm not
I needed to do to better myself and at
the time where I was so bad like you
know we're talking
six-six kid was uncoordinated hasn't
been running and just like I was it was
so weird so awkward for me man so I got
out there in the first game he drop you
know I'm out there playing
I got always always remember we'll be
like you know their game situation
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] was serious [ __ ] serious so
literally he says that he says he said I
got something I want to show you and
like I watched the waterboy before with
Adam Sandler yeah
hostess you don't say teenager chill
happy next one sucks but he shows it to
me and you showed it to me and he's like
he's like you see how clean his face he
put his face when I got you got anybody
you like it's cool put the face on that
[ __ ] treat him like that next
week and we're playing Southern Maryland
I'll never forget there was just other
big kid six five
he's about 380 pounds the other big kid
and on inner in the lead and so I don't
remember telling myself like you know me
[ __ ] this kid up I'm gonna jump on top
sort of also the first place yeah he
lines up over me all his snap I kid you
know I'm not even kidding you and it's
pressed a little bit more thematic and
I'm explaining it but less dramatic but
so I'm driving the kid for about ten
yards and like my helmets in his chest
and I'm just running and the whistle
blows and I just hit leaves the game my
dad came all the way to the sideline
okay this is how you play ball like this
is how you do and uh row like I see
that's just Brady to what I what I am so
it's I love that yeah man and then you
know so from there you know I was gonna
ask you that's your so how old are you
when you first you 13 your first year
playing I'm 13 okay so the next year is
high school or you go what what i
schooled you go to a Maryland so I went
to do Matthew 14 and real quick there's
I just saw a promo for this basketball
thing I think it's on Showtime and
they're profiling PG counselors yeah and
the
[ __ ] athletes that come I mean this
one specifically I think is just
basketball but there's so many good
athletes from that we had Maryland area
man it's crazy yeah when I was at high
school there my freshman year was Victor
Oladipo was on the basketball team on
Jeremy grant who's in the NBA now house
Quinn cook had just left Josh show he
had just left he was a guy to play in
the NBA for a little bit um I'm trying
to think of some other names in there I
miss him but they'll come back to me
never day well it was it was a hole that
actually was just crazy to me man
because he knows basically the math
isn't Decius our way from from Baltimore
so you know and now in an explaining
that if I'm ready you know for like
about that time that's where I'm at best
yeah I mean I I went to Liberty High and
we knew I mean I played soccer I didn't
play play but we played you know and we
knew like when you talked about the top
football team and not we're not talking
about Maryland he this is one of the
best in the country is to always be math
at the math at the math yeah so okay so
you go and says you're you're one year
into your football career and now you're
you're in high school yeah so I go into
high school man I'm still heavy as hell
I'm probably at this time 420 pounds
instead of 450 and then I go into high
school as a freshman hold high and
hoping that I can make varsity there was
no way in hell I was raised for water in
my mouth
I was just like it was just I was so out
of whack I was not a good save and so
that was like the first time I had you
know like really done something super
organized with all which structure with
school with football with going to
practice and all of this and I remember
like after training camp ends which was
so hard for me where I got so many I can
tell you a goofy a story about training
camp but my freshman year so years ago
this is gonna trigger so my dad had an
Alienware laptop right and so like like
Alienware laptop you used to be like
listen I'll let you borrow it just don't
watch porn on my [ __ ]
so I told you a super hilarious but I
actually I actually asked you like the
next day like shaggy the deccan are like
[ __ ] you never almost stuck so something
you are
okay you talk about whatever my freshman
year man just learned his stuff it was
all used art he started on defense first
yes actually that's where I everything
we started at a high school freshman
ball playing on me Taku didn't feel like
I was capable playing online which I was
it and then my sophomore year you know
which is a year my dad passed like
that's when I like like started let me
play bar scene I didn't have me on
junior varsity I was basically just a
backup on varsity and so um you know it
was hard for me at first I really even
understand like man you know this guys
out there my grade you know that I felt
like I was better than and you know
Coach didn't want to play me or whatever
it was but you know long story short so
basically my setup and DeMatha was
because it was an hour away from my when
we lived on the harbor like right off
the Harbor in Baltimore on dad so the
math was like legit like 59 minutes hour
away from the Harvard so but my
grandfather he lived in Northeast DC
stay with my dad grew up so I would
stayed there with my grandfather and my
uncle Leroy and they would basically
commute me to school during the weeks
and so my dad dropped me off on Monday
I'm pretty much in DC till Friday I go
home stay with my dad Friday Saturday
Sunday dad dropped me off at school on
Monday okay so my 10th grade year man it
kind of get set but hey my 10th grade
year first week of school second week
the school third week of school okay so
I'll never forget he drops me off he
drops me off and [ __ ] phantom yeah
like 11 cars like he's like she's like a
dog give me some was funny I was like
hell yeah she was like I got some money
left over he's like [ __ ] take this [ __ ]
[ __ ] just threw $200 at me a drop off
the last time I see the Rose
last time I put the senior bro but like
not like I appreciate that [ __ ] cuz like
[ __ ] man like that [ __ ] still such a
vivid good memory
you know and so that's so like so we're
going throughout the week and but the
weekend that weekend I had a unofficial
visit at the University of Maryland
which was my first college visit and
like he wasn't feeling well enough to go
with me so I was like you sure you don't
want to go there's like no I'm just drop
you off go hang out wait Brendon so I
was like okay cool so I do that you know
go through the whole little weekend and
everything and he drops me off on Monday
gives me the lunch money and [ __ ] he
texts me on Tuesday like damn man really
not feeling well and you come back home
to help me out a little bit so I said
okay I was like okay and I didn't drive
at the time like I need that house key
man my parents had a crazy ass to work
bro shoes just like unreal so my dad had
his weirdest trust issues would be about
brothers have a cell phones the keys at
shoes where does [ __ ] ever so I didn't
even have a set of keys to the [ __ ]
house man so so literally saw I tell my
uncle Leroy because he was the one that
did all the driving and everything's my
grandfather's blind so I'm like ugh man
my dad saw me a text she said he's not
feeling well I was like [ __ ] I think I
you know I think I need you take me home
tomorrow after practice and [ __ ] man
well you know I got a working [ __ ] you
know let's just do it on Thursday I'll
take you on Thursday
you know I'm like all right well [ __ ]
never text me like this you know I'm
like [ __ ] man he like never text me like
that
and so I was like [ __ ] man you know like
I think it's more urgent than that but
as I heard up and so go to Tuesday
called him on Wednesday which was the
last time I spoke to him September 21st
and 2011 and so I'm talking to him on
the phone or I got into a fight with a
kid at practice my [ __ ] dad my dad I
[ __ ] told this [ __ ] that was
wandering goggles I was like [ __ ]
dongle started fogging up he's at home
like telling me you know he had to stay
consistent with that [ __ ] you know just
keep working understanding like you know
none of this [ __ ] that she was gonna
happen without she working you gotta
take everything that you wanted his
football [ __ ] nothing is for granted and
so that was our last conversation and I
remember he came downstairs and my
grandfather was like hey I want to talk
to him see I'm feeling called him back
he didn't answer so Thursday so I'm
calling them all day Thursday my damn
man I answer him I get between lunch
breaks and [ __ ] like that calling them
on a per diem and okay this is [ __ ]
weird you know and and so Thursday after
have to practice rows around my uncle's
I already will shoot you up there you
know because I think I had a reading
book for class as well so I'm on my way
on my way to Baltimore and everything
calling doesn't answer get they're not
gonna do or like you know not answer the
door I go around back both the
terrorists look in the look in the
window in the kitchen window I can see
his phone in the costume I am okay so
maybe he just [ __ ] sleep you know I
called the house calling it an
interesting either and so man who was I
see alright we'll get your book don't
worry buddy just tell you teachers a
[ __ ] excuse you be alright so we
drive back to DC
Friday rolls around which is game day
and now I'm calling my dad called him I
did I call him my dad and so I don't
know where Harry is Sheridan at the time
was like his assistant slash lawyer you
know I answered the phone and she's
crying I'm like [ __ ] was a hair it was
going on she was like your dad said your
mom's on the way of school to come get
you and your brother so I'm like well
[ __ ] man this is [ __ ] weird and so so
literally saw go through the dance at
Catholic school you know the methods of
Catholic school so I'm sitting in class
me and my brother actually had a history
class together the weirdest [ __ ] ever
mr. Brown was the [ __ ] teacher
[Laughter]
so we're [ __ ] in there and mr.
Brown's like we just want to say a
prayer for for Orlando Destin and the
class you know he says the prayer
classes prayer and [ __ ] principal comes
in grabs us and welcome
always [ __ ] teachers in the hallway
my man what the [ __ ] is going on so I
put this in a prince of principal office
and me and my brother Justin sitting
down and I like the timer ahem I like
basically my first cell phone and I got
it just made a Twitter and my I had got
a tweet that said RIT Zeus and I was
like I remember like a little and I'm
still a lot and I asked the teacher that
I utter the principal I said there my
dad passed he was like he just walked
out the room I remember like [ __ ] man my
brother started crying and he was off
type 1 diabetic and everything since he
was in fourth fifth grade so you know
now our dad was like like in our life
completely you know I mean and full full
man like I'd say yeah full custody I
lived with him from around 13 so it's
open to the point where you passed and
uh man it was just like that [ __ ] was
just so [ __ ] crazy for me bro
and yeah it was just like cuz you know
it was like holy [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] hit fastest thunderstorm went
outside bad rain and man I've never
[ __ ] from your brothers just crazy
[ __ ] ever my brother Justin he's like
[ __ ] although he was not betting
[ __ ] athlete of the family he can do
ten times [ __ ] I can doing all of that
and or as a satyr should ever man he
[ __ ] I remember like we were leaving
and he's like listen brahmaloka leaned
on my locker man I can't do this
football [ __ ] like that was my
motivation and I was like what he's like
bro I can't I can't play this [ __ ] no
more man I like for me it was it was the
passion and the love that he sold when
he was there I just he's like without
that I can't do it you know and like
[ __ ] or he never play ball again Wow
yeah manases that's just [ __ ] wild
girl but that like that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like it changed me completely you know
you've been through a girl like that the
next day is really the hardest [ __ ]
day because it's like holy [ __ ] that's
true
you know it's like what my dad died when
I was 16 and he had just he actually was
in Hopkins so the the short story was he
had just gotten out of the hospital we
spent Thanksgiving weekend in
Highlandtown at my aunt's
down in the city and cuz it was close to
the Hopkins and case some [ __ ] went down
we're just gonna burnt gonna move them
all the way out the Carroll County we'll
go right there
then we went out and we still had that
Monday off and that's Sunday night it's
just different everything's different
you you look back on in sucanat so that
that was a different thing like you know
like your dad's phone on the couch and
the text getting a text like that these
things these these different things lead
up to it that you don't see until you
able to reflect back and we went out and
and I remember I was always up late I
was always up late but that night I
think I went to bed kind of early and I
remember stopping and looking back at my
dad and we had just gotten in trouble
because a buddy his parents got busted
us for having a house party it it's the
house we were involved in this party but
my dad was disappointed he was like he
was like I heard y'all we like look man
that wasn't us that's him we were there
but we didn't throw you know we weren't
promoting apart like we went I mean I
remember walking down the hallway and I
looked back at him iced I don't even
know why I stopped and looked back at
him watching TV on on the couch and then
I went to bed and we woke up my little
brother was waking us up saying like I
don't think that's breathing and yeah he
had a massive heart attack or a clot or
something that that killed him in the
night and we all three famine his bed in
the morning yeah it's all and you know
for you to be I mean and so you and I
and this is the this is the weird thing
and tell me what your experience was
like with this but we're children you
know and are I'm talking to adults my
friend's parents who their parents are
still alive they don't even know how to
talk to this kid about what's going on
cuz they've never experienced it
themselves and you very quickly realize
like I'll [ __ ] man I'm kinda on my own
here a little bit yeah no I'm not
seriously growing and like it's like
it's just so overwhelming next my
girlfriend she lost her dad when she was
52 you know its Agent Orange and she and
it was just like yeah and they're so you
know it's
one of those days where you know you
know the thoughts that you have and the
emotions and the feelings that you have
are just it's almost like a fear man
because like for so long in your life
that's what you knew and that's what you
had and you know man it's just like it's
just like scary it's hell man - to
really experience that you know as a as
a young man you know especially you know
I felt like I was just very so difficult
for me to really even wrap my head
around you know cause like now I'm the
man of the family you know for me and
and just like Cosgrove's just like just
so much so much things and this just
went into it I remember and I'm curious
what your experience was like with this
- you know they had allowed us to have
an excuse me it was an excused absence
in school if you wanted to come to my
dad's funeral and then I just remember
going back to school that first day
after all of it and I just I know
everyone meant well teachers students
friends but I just felt like I was in
this [ __ ] fishbowl floating through
these hallways with every set of eyes on
me some not knowing what to say some
saying things that they thought were the
right thing and I just remember feeling
like this I just felt like a [ __ ]
charity case and I hated it I didn't
want to feel like that you know from
that past man I was just like [ __ ]
school but for me whose it was they
really like man I'm just gonna play ball
but this is what I want to do and like
believe it or not like my dad passed
September 23rd I'm a Friday man I went
back to school I went back to school on
like the next Tuesday like it was always
just like my I gotta go back to practice
buddy
you know and then DeMatha losing Elsie
so if you don't go to class you can't
practice and so you know I was like [ __ ]
I'll just go through school today so now
literally just sit in a locker room like
for six hours a day when I'm practicing
practice and leave it at that
I just like for me ball was where like I
found comfort you know and releasing
that anger that stressed that fear of
man my casa I'm alone now
I'm 15 years old [ __ ] this my mom no he
is this you know all of those different
things that you dealing with you know as
a young man and you know your body and
mind has changed so much that it just
was so hard for me to really learn to
grab him at least so I just turn the
ball like that was just my coping
mechanism that you know I tried to me
you know the best of it and you know man
just from from that point on man I just
you know it's just always been shoes for
me you know to get where I am today and
and to do the things I do today and um
you know man that's just like you know
it's my dentist you know it's changed my
life completely man sports are saving
grace man it's the same exact thing we
just dove more in the sports cuz also
you're with your friends you know what I
mean and that's the that's the
camaraderie you need you got you got a
lot of [ __ ] anger and confusion and
you can take that out in that sport I
love the wrestling for that reason cuz I
would get to take it out on that per
that poor son of a [ __ ] over there
didn't know what I was going so so you
went the opposite way your brother did
it lit a fire for you and and I don't
know for you but for me like when I did
my very first network television
appearance on The Late Late Show I wore
my father's Pan Am crew chiefs shirt
because I wanted I wanted him to be
there with me I didn't wear it for a
look or an image or I'm blue-collar I
wore it because I was like man I want my
dad to come out there with me because
he's the one that introduced me to
comedy comedies my football and this was
my my Zeus you know and and just
recently - this is the thing - you're 24
wait T see how it just it just keeps it
never stops at Nick you go here first
times I'm in the grocery store where I
hear a song or something I'm like in the
frozen pizza sex and I'm getting all
emotional
oh my god I once there was a lady
cutting me some cold cuts at
Thanksgiving and her name was marmella
after I told her this story about my
grandmother and at the end of it I go
what's your name she goes Carmela that's
my grandma's day I got all I was like oh
[ __ ] I could you believe it but I just
last night I had some fans send me tops
had made a baseball card out of me and
they did these different versions of
them and one of them was like a game
worn Jersey card and they were like you
can put a shirt at whatever you wanted
so I took the jerk the shirt I wore on
The Late Late Show and I cut it up and
they cut it up into pieces and they put
it out in cards and now my father is
with me in baseball cards all over the
place that people having last night I'm
still I'm getting fired up I'm writing
some things down to talk to you about
I'm doing some extracurricular
activities out back getting some fresh
air you know what I'm saying and I got
it gone and I opened this little
envelope and there are two cards from
fans that want me to sign them and send
it back and it's the game-worn Jersey
cards and I instead of getting emotional
this time I laughed out loud like it was
my dad being like dude I'm so stoked for
you you know you're gonna be talking to
Suze to my I'm tellin ya that's the way
I feel about [ __ ] I still well I'm
wishing man I'm wishing then I like you
know my dad and crazy Department yeah
actually he passed on my brother
Justin's birthday so we have a lot in
common my father was buried on my
youngest buried on my youngest brother's
birth he's still not sure who was in
charge of those the funeral directions
but he was buried on he died on your
brother's how old was your brother on
that day I was turning 40
so he turned 14 so this is the same
brother that was walked out of the
school with you then right
it's his birthday his birthday yeah bro
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] man but brother like and
like what is crazy say that about the
tops cars though because you know like
like ever since he's passed I feel like
I see like and I said September 23rd I
always feel like I seen 923 on the clock
always see any 778 somewhere [ __ ] like
that and I'm sure you experience the
same she driving just look at the
license plate like I know and they grew
up the house they had in Baltimore was
11 11 Elm Road I went back one night I
came back to do some shows I tried a
couple drinks in me and I went to that
old house and I feel like improv I pride
you know you know Baltimore row homes
with a little bits a little piece of
wood on a diagonal it's got the house
number on it I went up and pride that
[ __ ] out of it like 300 sir from my
house and I took it I have it above my
door in my home now repainted it and
made it look nice and it's 11 and I see
11 11 all the [ __ ] time all the time
yeah and I just you know you know
whether is afterlife or not I believe in
it man but uh gosh I just look at that
as you know him you know let him letting
me know like [ __ ] I see you like you
know I feel like this is you know his
spirit his energy and that's me like you
know I'm just appreciative appreciative
for everything that he taught me open to
that point you know and it helped me
grow into Who I am today it just even
though you know [ __ ] he was a very wrong
Peter you know just like your politics
stuff you know with you know you
watching Richard Pryor which okay you
watch the spring a lot like your pops in
that way men I'm just fortunate man I
was able to taking in those things that
he talked yeah so here's the thing that
that still gets me so I want to talk to
you more because now moving forward
everything is bittersweet you know you
you go on - so tell us how what's
happening when you start playing varsity
ball are you getting a lot of recruits
or are you being looked at heavily
what's going on when you and and when
does that happen for you at an eleventh
grade tenth grade where are you and that
starts coming really [ __ ] bittersweet
bro because that's the truth but man so
I uh so basically after my dad has
September of 2011 my mom just to Atlanta
January 26 2012 so I just finished up
that semester at the math and then I
moved down south and I met Mark
Fleetwood was my high school head coach
throughout my time there in Georgia and
I mean it was just such a such that you
can impact the need growing up as a
person and as a young man that had lost
his father at the time and so I moved
down there and eleventh grade and right
away
Auburn Alabama Georgia Tennessee
Kentucky Florida and they just start
coming in and and you know my name
doctor cuz my high school coach was a
really good coach my high school was
[ __ ] Cameron Hayward in Pittsburgh
Bradley Roby and number and then Kevin
mentor at LSU and then there's no soul
you know man it was just like it was so
many guys that had come through there
before and we're successful with
first-round picks and NFL was considered
a hot spot at the time and when that
kind of football in Georgia is typically
where a lot of your ballers come from
you know you can look at the past you
know whatever is field three hundreds
and a lot of those guys on Fox are guys
in Georgia or in that County and so I
was playing against a lot of great
competition and man I just I just
consistently you know I started off
really rough my junior year just because
I spent so much time my sophomore year
taking in all the offers and come been
lying to myself about me being ready and
you know I'm gonna bawl out this year
without any focus on my craft any focus
on my body my conditioning and so I go
out there in that first game I'm getting
my ass tore up
and my Fleetwood was just like you know
[Music]
necessarily I didn't get like to take it
to the next level I just took you as I
make contact with my god resting into
the ground I didn't understand taking it
to the next level as far as my craft my
fundamentals and so that's when that's
when you know he sat me down in his
office and showing these big-ass cute
and kid I'll never forget he's like 618
sometimes supposed to go to Miami didn't
have grades goes in Middle Tennessee you
end up making it's an NFL with his high
school [ __ ] was crazy and get it find
[ __ ] so he's like big-ass kid out there
cutting safety tape linebackers flying
where I run around playing with
fundamentals playing hard and so so he
shows me that I said [ __ ] coach I said
coach I know exactly what you wanted to
see let me give it to you and man from
that point on the [ __ ] bro I just I feel
like from that point on I just
consistently got better every day I'm
still getting better every day man let's
take a quick break and tell you about
our first sponsor
Oh max cryofreeze living with chronic
pain is the worst
more than a feeling of discomfort it can
affect your whole life many of you
probably have some type of pain that's
prevented you from relaxing and sleeping
or stopped you from exercising perhaps
it's been ongoing for a few weeks now
and hasn't improved with any of the
treatments you've tried I've told you
I've been having this pain in my
shoulder my shoulder blade for months
now and every time it acts up I take
that roll-on boom hit it and it's it's
it feels so good it's relief quick and I
mean I got a cabinet stocked full of it
now for real Oh max health if you're
looking to get rid of nagging muscle and
joint pain immediately while providing
long lasting recovery then you need to
try the natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryofreeze CBD roll-on
developed by Oh max health Oh max health
is offering my listeners 20% off a full
bottle of cryo free CBD pain relief
roll-on plus free shipping this discount
also applies toward any product
site-wide so just go - Oh max health
calm today and enter code honeydew that
is Om AX health.com and enter code
honeydew to get 20% off cryofreeze and
site-wide and let's take a look at our
next sponsor blue chew guys remember the
days when you are always ready to go
well now you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence in bed listen up blue to calm
that's blue like the color blue blue -
brings you the first chewable with the
same fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis you can take them any
time day or night even on a full stomach
and since they're chewable they work up
to twice as fast as a pill so you can be
ready whenever an opportunity arises if
you could benefit from more confidence
where it counts blue chew is the fast
and easy way to enhance your performance
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy and it ships right
to your door in a discreet package
they're made in the USA and since blue 2
prepares and ships direct they're
cheaper than a pharmacy no awkwardness
and you don't have to leave the house
right now I got a special deal for my
listeners visit blue to calm and
get your first shipment free when you
use the special promo code honeydew
again that's blue2 dot-com promo code
honeydew to try it for free now let's
get back to the do and so you know
closely would at that point someone
[ __ ] hate his ass because I couldn't
understand why but you know I got it as
the season went on our this is like
minutes Thank You coach I needed that I
need to be said that I needed to be put
back in place because I was at the time
I was hiding behind those offers hiding
behind all that [ __ ] not keeping the
rule of myself because I was trying to
run away from the loss of my dad running
away from you know going to class and
all that different type of stuff so you
know when I got down there I didn't hit
the ground running but once it got lit
[ __ ] was the [ __ ] have a great spring I
wanted to mark my senior high school
actually I committed Tennessee may 2nd
yeah yeah I was committed to University
of Tennessee and I mean that whole story
to is going I'm explaining it as we get
closer but um yes I commit to Tennessee
at 17 on my 17th birthday and that's my
junior year going to my senior year man
I had two three four visits there well
yeah I just felt as a family atmosphere
that opportunity for me fella thought I
could play the freshman I was crazy [ __ ]
and so go to my senior year I mean I'm
sitting down talking on five star guys
I'm playing my ass off other colleges
like at the time you know like I had
pretty much lost all my scholarship just
because I was committed in Tennessee so
you know like it was it was literally
just Tennessee now Oklahoma coal soos
cause be tomorrow line coach they will
still be writing me letters state me
like you know hope everything is going
well and you know if something ever
happens to Tennessee hit us up so they
would just consistently you know write
letters and so December is of my senior
year high school and Fleetwood called me
in his office he goes hey Tennessee SC
transfers now I have been running from
this [ __ ] for years both
[Music]
tell your business I've been on there
like so you can get time favors do was
access to your transcript I'm like hell
naw like next question you don't really
so like my GPA atop see it was a one
point seven years I don't want to do any
school after what you don't want to do
anything after that you know the the
look at your brother you know he was
like I'm done with all of it yeah I'm
out and you know I treated like that
when I which I shouldn't have been and I
don't you know that that just said to me
so far behind coming in as a freshman
Oklahoma but anyway so you know I'm like
totally what do I do
he's like [ __ ] you gotta send the
transcripts many money they got a notice
[ __ ] but you know you can't hide it
trying to dated two months somebody
alright so they send transcripts the
coaches find out they come in have a
meeting with me and my counselor can he
qualifi counselors like yeah but he
needs for aids for three days and or
four A's and one beat to qualify and
he'll be he'll be good
he's like she said he's got one AC team
but I think he slept the whole time for
the 13 I'm committed to school right so
some time passes man January Jenny where
I'm supposed to come up like for an
official visit in January but it was an
AC T like test that day so I was taking
every test all the way up until you know
I needed what I needed so there was a
test on my January 15th or something
like that and it was also an official
visit weekend so I told them like hey
look I'm staying take the SAT test you
know and then we can just set up my
official visit for later okay
and so they were like okay cool so I'm
waiting to take the SAT test and I told
you my brother type one diabetic so he
goes into a soup like you know and I
don't know if you're familiar with
diabetes at all but when someone sugar
tonight they they wake up but there's no
body function so like he needs sugar in
his blood in his bloodstream to even
function so I wake up at 7:00 a.m. and
you know I'm just checking out with
everybody like standing on the head
novel now looking there and I just
noticed that he's breathing but his and
his eyes are open but I'm like Jay you
all right and I could just tell like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is not good you know and
so that was like the second time that I
had witnessed something like that with
him and song my gosh [ __ ] and so
immediately I called 9-1-1 and I like I
learned his weird-ass trick man cuz I
noticed that like a shoe basically they
shoot like glucose into his bloodstream
directly with the noggin when people do
wakes him up he's good to go can go on
by this day so I was like [ __ ] man you
know I know he can open his mouth I know
he can't necessarily communicate I was
like [ __ ] I wonder if I'll [ __ ] pour
some syrup on this [ __ ] telling you
feel swallow this [ __ ]
you're good with straw and some artists
do something Sarah would do with this
well so I go downstairs but I get some
angel mama cereal and I clear on this
[ __ ] tongue and within my probably up
I'm out this [ __ ] my drink he
probably just like sugar this [ __ ] went
from being like [ __ ] 25 like 700 row
it's like the coach calls me the next
day hon SAT got something what happened
where I wasn't able to make it
you know I deal with specifics about
like [ __ ] and my brother went to sue
they know he's not Betty and so okay all
good we're gonna set your official visit
date for two days before Sunday so I'm
like okay cool like you know it's only
two hours two hours away Tennessee from
Atlanta thanks Bill and so time passes
me and my mom my brothers would go up
and everything and I could just tell the
whole time and energy sweeter Energy's
real weird like you know with the
dynamic of the coaches and everything
and so we get to the last day everybody
meets coolest Jones they told me I'm the
last guy that's going to meet with my
okay waiting around all day and man
[ __ ] well I get in there I get in
there what was Jones just me it was
Jones and my mom who's had closed its
not and they had like the academic
counselor something for the football
team he was they pull it on my
transcript of my grades and my a CT
score and it was just like hey you're
not gonna qualify we don't have a
scholarship we're not gonna see you a
scholarship on signing day but we got a
junior college options for you and I'll
never say my hey you know you're coming
from I get what you're saying but like I
got friends that aren't gonna get a high
school diploma coming off its first
thing tomorrow morning on Monday so I
going on Monday and I go see what the
hell are you trying to do
I Fleetwood's like he's not [ __ ] I'm
gonna tell you what happened they got 33
connects you only have 31 scholarships
available you and this other kid you're
leaning on
oh great situation cuz me and one other
kid he's like they're gonna try to say
that you guys are unqualified so they
can give these other guys for
scholarships basically and they oversee
so I said holy [ __ ] no way and so you
know he asked me he said well you know
he gets him a phone kirsanov is also
credited with Tennessee and he actually
gets off the phone with UT he says he
says you know so where you want to go I
was like man I said she said you know
South Carolina
they'll reoffer you sure Alabama will
they didn't offer re offered
Kansas Ohio State Urban Meyer was real
big real big on me
cleansing so like those schools have
reoffer and he was just like man where
you want to go and I said man coach I I
know it's strange I know it's weird I
said man but I feel like the right place
amigos Oklahoma and I had never visited
Oklahoma the University never met with a
coach didn't know what does what the
hell I thought it was too weeds out in
your courses so you know he was like you
sure you want to do that I was like whoa
[ __ ] coach I I think it's the best thing
for you like you know it's far away from
home but not too far and man I feel like
I feel like you know they they put out a
lot of in a fella town and so on the
phone with Bob Stoops so he got on the
phone with Coach Stoops and we basically
explained to him the situation and I was
just like hey hey listen listen [ __ ]
I'll send your ass to scholarship all
that you just sign it just sign it you
sign it we'll take care of rest we'll
get you in here when you get in here
we'll make sure you qualify so now I end
up signing that student sign the day it
came in probably ten minutes before it
[ __ ] fine it ended I signed [ __ ] man
they help me you know get with the right
people and the right things
ain't no qualifying late I had to take a
summer classes [ __ ] end up qualifying
and like my first day on campus was like
July 26 2014 and man I saw a training
camp starting on lights at Lots 28 and
don't like I said bro I had done
that's it that [ __ ] was just such a rude
awakening for me when I got here but
prior to that like going into like my
senior year man I had my meds more Brown
right and so like he was someone that
was familiar with my dad played an NFL
at a high level Pro Bowl all pro player
went to Oklahoma here so you know I got
to know him a little bit over the time
and when I got here to Oklahoma like
obviously he went here he lives here in
the offseason so I just really got the
Norma be around more and Mambro like
literally you know he took me in like
one of his home and you know I was so
fortunate to have him in my life you
know and I still have him in my life man
the the things that he was able to teach
me that like I didn't get from my dad
you know and I was in an angel Fleetwood
you know I was getting things from Coach
Stoops and my old line coach foot man
Jamal like helped me out so much
understanding and you know good lessons
right there watch it 50 60 foot you know
it was his little lessons like that that
was so important for me and man I just I
met him I said got around him a bunch
and I mean just from there bro like I
just feel like he helped taking my work
ethic to another level and gosh you know
I read started my freshman year other
behind to to tattoo tackles that ended
up getting drafted and at the time it
was to register to use and then going to
my race car freshman year the next year
2015
which was like man our keycard our
freshman class at Oklahoma and it was me
Baker Mark Andrews came on dorial
green-beckham
gosh bro Dede Westbrook I mean just so
many big names and Joe Mason sometimes a
pure yeah there's so many guys that like
came in with us and you know we just you
know picked off for them and never been
tallied and they're approaching Dawson
just Nolan from there man and I was able
to basically win exotic as a redshirt
freshman man I beat out to seniors and
[ __ ] I started every game from there on
out and gosh man Holly was not easy in
any way football but I got better over
charm so let me ask you this like what
are you going through emotionally like
you're you're now leaving your family
that you know in Atlanta and going to a
place you've never been to you know I
was the same coming to California like I
left ever I'm not I mean I'm not I like
to think I'm a man I'm a man but I'm not
even gonna lie to you I cried from
Maryland to Tennessee on this trip every
smelt the distance getting farther away
you're like I'm on my own this is real
now so like are you what do what do you
feeling with like do any of these
coaches or anything play with your dad
no your dad like is there anything there
for you to talk or resource or anything
like that and what are you going through
like I'm sure like I said it's
bittersweet you got to be so stoked like
holy [ __ ] I'm going to [ __ ] Oklahoma
I wish my dad was here yeah exactly like
that man like you said like I remember
you know I was when I got that call you
know from from the counselor that I you
know made the Pro Bowl as alternate [ __ ]
man that [ __ ] was just so hard for me
because it's like holy [ __ ] man you know
he's not here to see that and I got us
you know and my girlfriend said
something to me a few months ago man
like we were just talking about our debt
and uh you know she mentioned like her
baby staying in life that she struggles
with as far as it is that he never is
able to see her as a grown woman you
know and you know like she's like gosh
like you know although you know it's
biers alone I just I wish that I was
able to be a con woman and and you know
he could see who I became
you know what he was still here on earth
and I wasn't you know I'm totally man
you know I saw that a hundred and ten
percent you know all the way through man
it's just like this is always a
bittersweet with everything that I do in
life and listen that's never gonna stop
like you know I I saved it I've got a
wouldn't say this to the moment you
pulled the Mar across that goal line
I'll bet your dad like a god ape [ __ ] on
that one right there for sure like how
much fun do you think your dad would
have watching this you guys just
practicing [ __ ] to like to watch like
like that but you're 24 how old's your
girl she's 28
so way to become parents and then you're
it's all over again like that's the
greatest moment of my life
so for me my daughter was born October
14 2014 and I'm holding her and I'm
crying because I'm so happy and I'm also
like crying because man I'm a dad I
can't even I can't ask my dad any
questions like how the [ __ ] do you do
this how did you do that how did you do
that but the one thing that made me feel
great was and you you know as a Maryland
boy the Orioles were into goddamn
playoffs for the first time in forever
and I'm watching it in the hospital I
remember my daughter's mothers like
we're not watching sports and I said
listen to me we're paying for this
[ __ ] pregnancy and that Oriole
team is going on this damn TV i sat
there and held my newborn daughter and
watched him lose because the Royals were
the same they were it's it's rare that
you get to exact same teams and they
were like the same to I was like [ __ ]
and he made like a couple more plays a
game than we did and it ain't a goddess
but that's the only thing the eased you
know if just felt like I grew up going
to Memorial
Stadium with my dad and I remember
walking up the ramp and seeing the green
grass and being at these stadiums and
now I'm holding my daughter and here the
Orioles are back in the playoffs it was
again everything is just so [ __ ] but
and it never stops it never stops you
know I'm I wouldn't I wouldn't know that
[ __ ] comes and gets me every now and
then I'll just be sitting there going
god I wish I could ask my dad how the
hell he did this ya know I'm with you
Nana I see that's the hard part about it
though you know losing someone with that
type of impact in your life you just
can't you can't get the questions that
you want you know what I mean it's like
[ __ ] man I wish I could press a button
ask a question you know I mean like the
thing is you can get answers from people
but I don't want the answer from you you
know what I mean like you can ask
anything you can ask a million people
the same question you get a million
answers I want your answer and I can't
get those do you want I want to get back
to what's happening in college here in a
second but do you ever have vivid dreams
your father like moments of your dad
yeah that's crazy you say that I
remember so somebody that I really spoke
to a lot of stuff about that was I had a
strength coach in college Nicola who
lost his dad as well when he was in his
20s in college
and he was very big in charge he was
like a drummer searching enormous so
then I would always talk to him and I'd
be like man delicious cotton in our
[ __ ] and I don't have him so much
anymore like I like yeah I haven't
knowledge it's not as intense and vivid
as they were in it but I'm like man I
had a dream last find them with that
came to me told me I'm doing that I
could fit like yeah you know like [ __ ]
he's it's like that's the spirit you
know that's God and understanding of
everything that's going on in your life
and where you're at and you know take it
as a positive [ __ ] and that [ __ ] was
scary for me for a while yeah all right
so now you're at Oklahoma and your
freshman year and you walk us through
the next few seasons yeah so [ __ ] man
until 2015
now no that was the first year I started
um you know it was baek's first year in
marquee all of us man
oh whatever from in Hollywood came in my
last year my racer engineer okay yeah
I'll tell you all about that [ __ ] that's
so funny as [ __ ] it was a it was a
similar issue with Lamar - I'll tell you
when we get there but uh like you know
so yes I'm a 2015 man you know as my
first year starting I win the job over
to red shirts to use these guys have
been the program for five years then he
closed his coach Riley trusted me coach
stoops and coach beaten bone man they
they saw how hard I was working my ass
off and everything and man it was just
like hey look you know we gonna meet you
guys start left tackle job and this
year's loose I was like well should I
can tell you how I never gonna lose this
[ __ ] so you know I would only
have a really good freshman year I
wasn't certain since his freshman
all-american but I was on a few teams
and then uh you know we end up losing
the playoff the cleansing but I had
played against a lot of top talent in
[ __ ] ball like I mean I played my ass
off you know being mightier okay I'm
gonna guess all these you know top
talents and stuff and so my wrist her
sophomore year we uh which was another
really good year for us we started off
kind of slow
I played okay against Ohio State and
those guys at the time you know it
wasn't my best game Houston I played
okay you know I had I gave actually
giving [ __ ] secretary miles and rose
it was [ __ ] but uh yeah so we
started off that year kind of slow and
then we ended up finishing really well I
remember uh man we were so close to
making a playoff so we had just beaten
Ohio State we would have been in and you
know they told us we were playing in
Sugar Bowl against Auburn and SEC and I
remember telling the officer Lionel I
hey it's our minds right this [ __ ] about
to be a [ __ ] blood we were [ __ ] we
out here with a double punch diving and
reloading his friend [ __ ] so it's a wise
right they asked man we like
and all those like I mean very clear
they were just all pretty much first
round second round picks this year and
this year's draft and uh man but we kick
they ass man I'm you know I never had so
much fun in the game I was talking so
much crazy [ __ ] but uh but uh yes so we
go through that and then going into the
season of my last year here I understood
that you know I could had an opportunity
to leave and I didn't have my mind set
on necessarily leaving but you know I
had my mind set on my position myself in
position to leave and so man I just I
went to work you know work my ass off on
my craft and my fundamentals I got
better at my body was was better in the
best state to have been had been in an
acquaintance I went on Ohio State was
like our first big game is [ __ ] Nick
bolsa and yeah him Hubbard and Taekwon
Lewis and I mean they had all of these I
mean everything their whole deal I'm
[ __ ] drastic man and so I went out
there playing - awesome you soon and I
should just really set out set the
foundation for the rest of the year you
know I was able to become a unanimous
all-american and gosh we made it to the
playoffs we end up losing the Rose Bowl
shatters [ __ ] ever trying to listen and
I was able to go to Atlanta to war shows
and big football fan slamming a year in
man so guys college at Oklahoma was so
much fun bro
I mean I got so many bucket stories like
as far as like you dogs tell you my
Hollywood so if I'm Hollywood bro how it
comes in all you I remember seeing him
I'm like someone's is it I said man I
said coach B [ __ ] this is 17 16 year old
can't y'all got here on his official
visit he's like nah man he's Duke okay
accountant he's like sage for Florida
exotic Ali he was like [ __ ] yeah yes yes
we started junior college we're talking
shoes let's just so you know I was all
JUCO at Catonsville Community College
for soccer and I'm telling you gospel
early cuz I know you
[Laughter]
they're beating up Essex and Dundalk and
all the other community colleges Zeus so
he came out of Cali here huh yes so he's
originally from Florida same areas Lamar
but he went to Junior College in
California I guess it was his best
opportunity and he actually he was
working at Six Flags while he was in
school I I didn't realize it was the Six
Flags out here yeah yeah minutes like
you know yeah a pretty you know life
fish it was getting out the mud for real
he's on your side [ __ ] so you know fast
forward somebody's at oh you in the
spring
my man this damn dirty got on big as a
[ __ ] small sick man you got some
growing to do dawg so the talk they talk
all offseason was we had just lost EP
Westbrook
they're like yo got somebody fasten this
markys brown kids faster than you so
they were in line bro I mean this
[ __ ] fly but he was so fast that
thanks arm wasn't big enough so the
early stages on his spring ball and fall
can make he was throwing the ball
throwing these [ __ ] these deep Brasi
verticals he came to borrow marques cuz
he's he's own he's got so much
separation Oh
blow down slow down man so like as the
season as a season started going on
Oklahoma's real big highly performing
practice is the opportunity you'll get
the play especially at the receiver
position is so many skilled guys
and so marquees just kept getting better
and then they kept getting on a better
page and bro I remember the Oklahoma
State game I believe someone that got
hurt before they were like Marquis you
up and looking at my tumblr chip are you
ready and just I had them go from saying
you tore that [ __ ] up and it was a same
with a similar vision we got the
Baltimore with Lamar Lamar's like we're
listen you too [ __ ] fast slow down
low so I can get you the ball you know
cuz I guess like the best way I could
explain it is you've got a guy that has
that much separation that quickly it's
hard for a quarterback to diagnose where
he wants to put the ball on the spot
it's sorry I like that that's the issue
that a lot of quarterbacks have ran into
with him at first but once they get I
mean [ __ ] bro it's like huh like a hot
fire degree starting excuse Hollywood or
Lamar well Marty's a martyr he's like a
listed you can't you got broke he is a
different level of fans it's kind of
weak but it's a straight line does
Hollywood take it in a straight line
[ __ ] it's close dog I bet you know I bet
she was close like it wouldn't be a long
shot but man hell of a race I'll tell
you that - yeah that's crazy man I saw
his videos Hollywood working out in the
backyard you know what I love about that
like they're right there at this school
there's a whole neighborhood around it
didn't even know those guys are over
there practicing right there you know
what I mean they yeah see that video
baby god damn mom they were right out
front like yeah they were right there
no you say that I've been I was with we
played Cincinnati last year me Lamar
Marquis we went to the - seven robberies
we went to the mall and then after we
left the mall he was like man I'm hungry
[ __ ] let's go to Cannes
so we go to Cannes and Lamar's on
Instagram live in Cannes in Cincinnati
and bro out of nowhere like within ten
minutes of him being on lock's where
people just start showing up well I know
you had you were doing that show for a
little while and I hit John up I was
like you gotta have Zeus and Lamar
signed some many helmets for me so I got
both of you I got Lamar before he was
the MVP
I got Lamar well nobody listened on my
fantasy team last year I picked Marv I
picked Ingram I picked Mark Andrews I
was picking people nobody picked and
then they were like you want to trade
and I was like now we're gonna run this
league this year alone I mean come on
yeah well I killed everybody they didn't
I was I kept telling everybody pick
Hollywood Brown I'm telling you get him
late you get him I took him early I took
him right away I was like imma get him
and I stayed at Tucker and the Ravens D
yeah I mean it was a year last year
stupid thing - we're gonna get back to
Oklahoma in a minute but all these
records you guys said all these numbers
that Lamar and it was a game basically
he sat out the equivalent of almost if
not maybe even a full game so to imagine
the numbers that he could have padded if
he was in there the whole time we the
only reason he sittings cuz you guys
were kicking the [ __ ] out of some people
and it's like no sense of getting hurt
in there like you know let's see what
else we got and get somebody else an
opportunity - and plus you get to [ __ ]
like one of my all-time favorite Ravens
is Marshall yonder and
getting a block next to I mean another
hall-of-famer there is no doubt and I
used to I mean I'm just so proud of
Baltimore and everything like and I love
seeing again the underdog he's the only
lineman on NFL top 100 I want to see you
I want to see you on that NFL top 100
he's the only offensive lineman on that
whole [ __ ] top 100 I think that would
give voters yeah what he was and you
know except football aside for a minute
what he the type of man he is
like as a father as a husband as a
friend well I mean I've never
necessarily been around anything like it
that's what makes him so unique and just
the way they grow he took me in like I
mean [ __ ] I got drafted I'm like a
Friday she's gonna phone me on Monday
you know me about yeah you talking to me
about something talking to me about
Baltimore talking to me about the system
and the ports of being a pro and all
that stuff and you know man that was
just so real for me authentic for me too
for a 12 year 11 year bedtime so like
you know I'm retiring so to him
obviously but man he called me right
away you know he's just going over
everything about you know being a pro
and you know when I got to build and I
start working with him and everything
and you know man just everything he's
saying about you know with the tape from
you know coaches and you know what you
doing your free time what you're doing
on offseason you know your focus at
practice every day your driving
motivation and aggressiveness and on
Sundays and and just you know things you
talked about it's far being a dad and
being a husband and and all the letters
were stubborn he knows this isn't route
by the type of guy to use I love that
dude man I love watching him play and I
was excited that you were getting to
play with him too is what a wealth of
[ __ ] knowledge to get to play next to
a walking encyclopedia football and then
to watch the guy then to watch the guy
[ __ ] hurt his shoulder go to the left
side and be just as goddamn dominant
that that'd be like asking me right now
Ryan take this [ __ ] one course of
Chinese and speak it fluently at the end
today and marshal yonder would have done
that [ __ ] matters position I can't have
you he's the [ __ ] bet he's the [ __ ] I
love them I love them [ __ ] deaf man I
just sex other dates a little more much
I miss them so all right back to
Oklahoma but things are heating up now
when do you start hearing like when you
start for you specifically when you
start hearing stuff about being drafted
in combines and and workouts and all
that like where are you at with that yes
basically the transition from college to
the NFL is like when there's transitions
every man it's like you know you're
you're not you're not on a team you know
you have no control of the team you're
going to it's just your minds and
emotions are all over the place
and you can't do anything but focus on
yourself and so from the point where we
lost that Rose Bowl game like I had a
feeling I was gonna leave I had to send
my brain in and everything and see what
they would say about my grade at the
time they can Riley little beaten vote
it was just like hey listen man you did
everything that you needed to do in
college to be in this position you want
the best tackles in this dress it's
right for the relief you know there's no
need for you to come back and I'm glad
they told me that you know cuz I I
needed to hear that from them but uh
would you would've gone back if they
didn't tell you that yeah most likely
most likely yeah you know if if they
felt as though you know like I wasn't
ready and they hadn't heard the right
things from scoffs oh yeah absolutely I
wouldn't want back men to make more
money I'm glad I did I think this is
dream come true you know and uh God so
so basically from that point picked out
my agent and everything just assuming
Joe payments at least first on you know
that's who represents you both of those
guys 50/50 and uh you know Joe's got a
bunch of big-name guys soon and does as
well
you know pathos is just more of the
office long guys so you know I feel a
little connection with in there and guys
from there man I was living
California training on getting ready you
know it for Kanban and everything like
that we're training out in California
yeah okay I was in second yep I was in
Santa Ana Mountains in Santa Ana from
[ __ ] basically January 6 the [ __ ]
like him there March April I was out
there pretty much living man I enjoyed
myself man I always wanted to live in
Caledon one to go to USC as a kid like
Ryan up like that was like in high
school but now I love that way like
someday when I'm 60 years old I hope I
can buy a house and he'll somewhere but
I'm sure you'll be able to buy a house
in the hills 80 year old ass is coming
over to cannon ball for your [ __ ]
diving board me yeah when I turned 60 mi
where no [ __ ] dross training
everything combine that [ __ ] was a
[ __ ] disaster you know man it was
just like [ __ ] it was such a bad
experience overall you know I'm not
someone that like man [ __ ] I just
started doing this [ __ ] 11 years ago you
know be like yeah it was eight years ago
I just started doing all this crazy [ __ ]
so now I live wasteful I got the
Cobblers really you know what I mean I
didn't train and way I trained till I
got the colors really and so guys where
I was like I felt like a football
standpoint absolutely
I'm still on but I'm so far behind
three guys of my size at my position
most guys my size they like [ __ ] and
Anna I used to be 220 and then I gained
120 pounds that's why
I was a play basketball and so you know
I was I was behind the eight ball
athletically men and I go out there you
know it teams you know I wasn't gonna
test flow it seems actually in my beats
you know like hey you know what are you
gonna test like you know what do you
miss is what's up in front of me what's
your 40 gonna be where you think
everything is gonna be and I told every
team I met with I said listen I'm gonna
works actually here like that's not my
game like that's not who I am that's not
my genetic makeup I'm the worst athlete
here I'm I had worse times most likely
and you know that's just that's just who
I am that doesn't mean I'm not ready for
ball and so you know the thing that held
me out so much
got that process that helped make me a
third-round pick was gosh it was you
know after the combine the questions
were about my work ethic and my
character and and you know I'm a big guy
yeah like you know is it gonna be weight
is the weight going to hold them back
this that and the other how much does he
love ball fortunately I had all of those
meetings with Baltimore I met with
baltimore probably the most like anybody
and so you know they were able to
understand my character you know how
much I loved the game how much I know
about the game how much I know about my
position how much how easy it was for me
to pick up the system and everything I
mean should not never end I got my first
official visit they're so confident like
all of those things played into a factor
and then I guess in some way you give
them comfort man to say you know look
you know he's athletic
I admire well I think we know the type
of guy we're getting you know and that's
it man first of all you can't imagine
art either you cannot that that's
something that you did you there is no
statistical measurement for heart and
for determination and for hustle it was
just not and the other thing too is it's
so beautiful because I'm watching a
draft and I'm like oh my God he's still
[ __ ] available he's still [ __ ] yeah
he's still available and they also knew
the person they were getting in the
character your character that they were
getting and and also like fortunately
for you a lot of guys aren't around as
long as Aziz
doing his thing like he could have known
you as a kid it could have been some new
people there that didn't even that that
didn t matter them or or resonate with
them at all so there's so many [ __ ]
things have to fall in place
yeah so yeah I'm sitting there watching
I'm like he is come on come on
and then when I saw I was like you gotta
be [ __ ] good like I was so excited for
you dude I was so excited like I'm
excited that you're in the NFL but to
get to play for my team I say my you
know but but I mean I bought enough
Ravens geared I should have at least a
peak down the tunnel or something every
now and then you ride at the Under
Armour Performance Center so so what's
happening on all right so let's talk
about like you had a most meetings with
Baltimore and then what happens when our
at draft night and where are you on
draft night like because all your god I
mean so many of you got drafted
yeah year so at the time I mean Mark
Andrews she knows like my best friend
then we came into college together we
got the same agents training yeah
they're drafted to the same team he's in
Arizona at time and so I'm accent here
in Oklahoma at a friend's house
Tom marksman he's a he's got like a nice
little eye area out here so I'm here I'm
here my mom my brothers Jamal and his
family are here and uh Tom stuffing so
I'm a sitting upstairs man and my den
the damn second round is going through
I'm like man this is sold out once the
first day I'm like I didn't expect to go
in the first day but I'm sorry the
attack was born I'm like like okay I'm
okay
so you know I got a first round he needs
whatever tomorrow is my day and so
second rounds going and I keep seeing
all these game towns get arrested so I'm
like man [ __ ] man like with you know my
gosh you know and no disrespect hideo's
that my team the guys from North
Carolina A&T all know the hell
so now I go downstairs I'm sitting
outside watching it on my phone my
DirecTV yeah and uh phone starts ringing
like a [ __ ] Coach Riley I said damn
in horrible he obviously meant money
should I just spoke to Buffalo uh yeah
asked about you you know they're coming
up here gonna turn around I think
they're gonna take a tackle you know but
they had just asked about you re so you
know just letting you know you know just
be on the lookout all right appreciated
coaches like I spoke to a few other
teams as well he named him office stuff
all right coach appreciated all the
magic city called me you know it's like
I just started you know maybe a few pics
and I'm just upstairs I'm sitting next
to my friend Quinn and I was on this app
man it was like the NFL Draft down to
some [ __ ] and I'm looking at the guys
getting drastic and it said Michael
Gallo - Dallas Cowboys who was like my
friend Quinn he was a junior college he
played ball with Michael guy who plays
$8 snarling he went to pick 82 or so my
daddy won and he was like all managing
with the Dallas where that's awesome I
was like hey Lea brothers don't [ __ ] in
my phone started ringing and said
Randallstown Marilyn so I've got two
sisters and their I got a sister who's
10 years I'm gonna be in 11 years so I I
had a sister with a renders town at the
time again I know she's not [ __ ]
calling me from her house phone and this
very moment right now I'm like damn so
originally I just swiped it and I was
just like hello and he said I said oh
[ __ ] I said no way you don't [ __ ]
clue me in purple and black I said
there's no way I know what you put me in
this [ __ ] he's like yeah we're doing it
we're gonna do it man
cos I'm treadmill here to make a one you
know you better come here with Mitch I
better work I was like listen you won't
get everything that you want anymore
this is you know my dreaming you know
believe and I didn't want to go to any
other teams man like you know for me it
was I really like New England I really
like Boston work you know and it was
more so about the culture you know that
those teams had and and you know the way
that they operate as far as business man
it's easy to respect it and you know
from from a professional standpoint so
now I really really wanted to get
dressed up there and I did you know I
knew that you know I was basically gonna
be a job competition for the right
tackle positioning James lang what's
what's going through your mind you're
get you're talking to you're gonna be in
a familiar place to you don't even have
to go even go in and learn a new play
you know the [ __ ] locker room
you know the stadium you know everything
I mean how overwhelmed I saw the NFL
Films when you finally hung up the phone
at a moment to yourself like how
overwhelmed are you like again
bittersweet like holy [ __ ] not only did
I make it to the NFL
I made it to my hometown team the team
my father played for my dad's go I mean
what is going through your mind during
this moment you know all those things
man you know I spent so much time away
from our sisters because of my mom
moving us to a later because of me
coming to Oklahoma like that was one of
the first things I thought about my kind
of getting the opportunity to be in
there watching him and and you know be
some positive impact no because I'm so
close to them but that was one of the
things that I really thought about him I
thought about my dad and you know just
how happy he would have been you know to
be a nosy that moment was because you
know I was you know and I was just
talking to coach talk about this last
season that towards the end of last
season
gosh and he remember - when I was 13
years old I just started playing ball my
dad would always get my equipment from
the Raiders so you know I go in my
cleats get like a little helmet
at that point and we see our ball on the
way out our cards and my dad and
everything and that was Tom no wooden
horse out of nowhere he just goes uh he
was gonna be around someday and I
remember saying saying him like yeah
yeah Ravens coats you know but it's like
if we rose is just so far fist you know
what I mean it's like yeah get in and
get in the NFL and have a cup of coffee
as hard you know what I mean yeah yeah I
mean you've accomplished something that
that the majority of athletes don't ever
accomplish I know that looks like
there's a lot because there are a lot of
NFL players but there are so many more
football players that never even get
this opportunity and then to go to your
hometown team where you know people to
[ __ ] play your dad's possess so were
you you they told they did tell you you
were you were gonna battle it out for
right tackle yeah let me know that my
damn meeting you know I hate you know
our right tackle position um it's gonna
be a competition area from try to um you
know Martin morning week was all see at
the time and everybody was just real
straightforward man like look you know
you know you're not coming in here too
and be a swing tackle for four years
you're coming out here to ball and it's
earth you know so so prepare like that
and I took that approach man and you
know I didn't end up winning the job
first one a job in [ __ ] great guy
great player you know and and he was
very he helped me out a lot as well just
as much as Marshall as far as being a
pro and doing things the right way
showing up on time and all that type of
stuff so you know there was no animosity
in there for me man I just took it as an
opportunity to location if I'm not gonna
be a starter in NFL I'm gonna be a
sponge you know and so I played a role
where I was basing like the six the six
old linemen where I come in on big
package that short yardage goal line
extra line and that type of stuff and I
block guys all that weird [ __ ] so you
know we go on with plants in and see my
Ricky and [ __ ] Alex Lewis gets hurt
and so normally in practice in those
situations they would kick James first
from right tackle the left guard and put
me in the right time okay in the game in
the Tennessee game I was playing so much
of the extra lineman package they put
Bradley Bozeman in at left guard left to
right tackle at me there
so that first I'm not [ __ ] in him I
don't know you know what my deal is
gonna be I hope you know hope hopefully
next week you know I could make my first
starting NFL and you know it was New
Orleans against cam Jordan and so so I'm
like trying to wrap my mind around that
and everything and literally man I
remember I came in on a Monday and you
know Coach D was just like hey you know
Joe Davis senators don't model uncle's
like hey you know starts a right tackle
this because they before you became cam
Jordan and there's a really good player
and you know I got nothing but the
utmost respect man for any guy that does
you know what cam George been able to do
Khalil Mac von Miller you know when you
can be that consistent at a high level
for so long yeah you gotta understand
you know what I mean and so man I had so
much respect for him and his play style
man but I just study my ass off and you
know they went to it with a really good
game plan for you know young rookie
tackle making his first start you know
basically a 4:15 kickoff under the right
sing man bro you know we
losing a game you know hold on because
I'm so I'm in such a big fan of you and
your story like I made my daughter's
mother and Derek we all sat down and
watched her little NFL the NFL Films
thing they did that little piece and at
the end when you're crying we're all
crying I mean I look over his mom she's
crying we're all crying rooting for you
like we love you so much so now tell me
what is it like when your kickoff just
happens and you're about to go out what
is going through your mind are you how
much of your dad are you thinking about
as you're running out to [ __ ] get in
that huddle yeah oh man I like for me
like what I remember before I like
attempted to like always tapped in front
of my neighbor back to my number and uh
you know I just always like to know I
just give myself like a boost of
confidence in that moment you know and
just let myself know what that number
represents but but before that I
remember looking up to like Section two
92 93 because that's where like our
suite was and I have this remember every
man like no I hear you are thinking
about that [ __ ] you know fart still
there because you know before that were
like [ __ ] goes what it's not like you
know it was literally you know at that
point you know he would have been eight
nine years ago man in ten years before
that man like you know I was just a kid
up there was my dad's like a Buffalo
Bills
you know what I mean and it locks and
everything like that she just moved me
so much in that moment but I was just
like our guiding ball I got a bow and
every before every show I walk out I rub
my lefty on my right arm before I
[ __ ] walk out I still did like my you
know I go back to being a little kid in
that house and I snuck down and saw my
dad watching this movie that I saw kids
in it and I thought all I'm allowed to
watch this movie there's kids and ended
up being Richard Pryor busting loose
when he was driving he was
five of the kids of the [ __ ] order
the bad kids to the orphanage and I
started laughing I got caught he said
get in here and I was like oh [ __ ] dad's
about to [ __ ] me up and he goes sit down
and I sat down and finished watching
this with me and that was it that was
the birth I was 10 or 11 that was the
birth of comedy for me and every time I
take the stage I like just a little take
them out there with me so I I'm just a
romantic about that kind of [ __ ] you
know what I mean so I I know you are I
can tell you are I know what your moment
yes
you go out your first game you get you
make Pro Bowl this year you make the Pro
Bowl and I feel like maybe it was in
that that little piece where or maybe
you had said it like you just or your
dad you your dad always talked to you
about what like one day you make the pro
ball I'll be down there hanging out with
you telling the old stories with the
guys and all that [ __ ] whatever beast
that would have been so much fun yeah
yeah man you know because he played for
13 years man but he never was able to
make a pro bowl and so like that was you
put something that like you know he
carried on in life like a deal almost at
like [ __ ] I never I never really
amounted to that you know as long as
although I was a highest-paid alignment
at one time and you know I set this guy
down did this you know he never
necessarily got that not in a public
vote and there's a lot of different now
than it was for him you know I know fans
of all media coaches players that then
bro it was just like should they vote
for the most famous or one
Jonathan I don't really know patience
those were you guys you know I'm stance
so you know my dad kind of looked at
crowds especially because at the time
right tackles man she didn't you know
they weren't they weren't as important
as they are now and you know it was just
it was just such a big deal for him to
make a Pro Bowl and and I got that
opportunity to the gold men and it was
just like that was hard you know for me
cuz he just fed and then you know I had
my brothers down there my sisters my mom
and everything I was like [ __ ] now I
really wish you know he could have been
a part of that to see that happen man
just they saw everything started you
know 13 years
I have two questions I want to ask you
one is what do you miss most about your
dad oh man
gosh what I miss most well that's a
question man uh miss a lot of things man
but guys I think I just I miss like I
just really missed out like are like
adult like conversations you know I'm
staying like and I'm sure you that I'm
like I remember like I remember you know
one of our conversations like he talked
to me about getting my first but you
know I didn't know anything about that
at the time then and how much were like
it is like like that's that for me you
know that's probably like the thing I
miss the most just like the adult
conversations and having a resource
there's a parent and a player and I mean
your dad with so many levels and layers
to you yeah your mom I think about this
all the time and especially as I get
older if you had 24 hours with your
father right now what would you do 24
hours probably spend the first at least
eight to ten on a boat in the Chesapeake
Bay fishing room my mind is damn near
the same I would I would if I had 24
hours we'd be on a wide river crabbing
like we used to do back in the day take
the boat out go crab bring the [ __ ]
crabs home we'll sit we'll have a crab
feast we're gonna watch the Orioles lose
in September and then we're going to MSE
to the bank and we're gonna watch a
Ravens Monday Night Football game with
Orlando Brown
Jr paving the way for Lamar Jack's and
that's what I would do mine and then and
then after the game I'd play catch and
talk to him until the [ __ ] Sun came
up and there'd be a rap out on the
Chesapeake you're right dude come back
to the crib and just talk some [ __ ]
watch some
oh yeah you know well I can't thank you
enough for coming on and opening up and
being so honest I look man when we can
get together and I want you to come back
as I know you got a million more stories
and when I get back to Baltimore maybe
we could do a live when it uh at Jimmy's
we should do a live one you know like I
do myself a season so you know all of
you is out there don't forget to name me
see food pretty much every Thursday
night Trevor your way in and grab pigs
in in the country in the world yeah
listen let me tell you something this is
healed a wound for me I don't know if
you know but I was supposed to be a ball
boy for the 1984 Baltimore Colts and I
told the whole story it's a there's a
link on my website I did it told this on
this is not happening on Comedy Central
and I mean my dad woke me up in the
night to watch the Colts sneak out of
town and the Mayflower's and there goes
the ball boy gig there goes my dad
season tickets like we're all crying on
the [ __ ] I was and then we lose
football and until 96 it did make me a
bit a better football fan cuz then I
started I wasn't just focusing on my
team only I started learning about
Walter Payton and you know Barry Sanders
and Steve large
Dave Craig and all these guys on other
these other teams but yeah man this has
been such a treat not you're such a
great do now you're a great friend and I
appreciate you for even giving me the
opportunity to sit here and talk to you
like this and and for you being so open
and honest about it so my last question
is advice to your 16 year old self
looking back now cuz you're only 24 so
it's not that long ago what would in
these last eight years what would you
tell 16 year old Orlando Brown jr. yeah
I would tell myself to be more honest
with myself now at that point I'm well I
definitely would have gotten ahead of
the curve as far as my work ethic you
know somebody that's always work hard
but you know maybe more than the next
man but not hard enough you know for me
and who I am who I was everything I
would tell myself to work harder I would
tell myself to take you as a class you
know I would just be you know tell
myself man just be more honest you know
and and I was just really in all assets
of life and whether that be girls put it
every ball you know and friendship spent
it's just being more honest and keep it
real bro like you know and I don't
necessarily recognize that till I was 18
you know Todd was 19 and I got away from
home and I learned everything that I
just you know those are those are two
things to me like Oxford I like you know
I could have I could have gotten head
and curve you know if I understood like
[ __ ] man my the importance of diet the
importance of hygiene and all that type
of stuff it's funny it's great advice
it's funny to say that too because I
really feel like with my father dying
and the way it went down cuz my mom had
already left to family so my brothers
and I were on our own at that point like
from 16 on world we're taking care of
each other and it certainly gave me an
education that I never would have got
had that not happened but I really feel
like it set me back 10 years in like I
didn't have anybody in the same thing I
don't have anybody showed me how to tie
a tie I didn't have anybody talk to me
about finances and saving money and
invest none of that I didn't have
any of that [ __ ] that would you would
hopefully normally get from parents and
and just advice and and I had none of
that so I feel like the the there was a
hindrance in some of aspects of my life
and while other things went forward in a
way where no other people even knew how
to deal with that kind of [ __ ] that you
know um and to this day I do I one of
the best and I want to say thank you to
Segura two because Tom's the reason I
got to meet you and the year before that
he was at the lyric which is the Modell
theatre now which I love that they named
the theater after art and the we did it
that I got to do stand-up at the lyric
and that's the one where like if there
was any show I wish my father and
grandmother could have seen that that
would have been the one that would have
been that's the [ __ ] lyric and one of
my friends wives said to me after she
said you just got to perform at the
lyric and Baltimore it's a pretty
[ __ ] big deal for a Baltimore kid
knows if you know what it is
thank you to succour alright that's one
question I do want to ask you of all the
games you've played whatever I don't
care College NFL whatever what's the one
you wish your dad could have been at I
gots a goofy a story by Ricky but the
one game and one game it was would it be
the Pro Bowl no man it would have to be
the first that first Pittsburgh am I
started in in Baltimore on my rookie
year they call the offenses although the
first time I ever went to the tunnel no
yeah man whenever they will call my dad
stadium will go soon yeah it's it's so
uh man Nate you know
starting at talkable endo Brown 78
Lander Browns you 78 and the whole
stadium just goes Seuss and I just
remember like I'm a little duck man like
you know like chills dude I got tilt
oh [ __ ] I was like bro and this is CJ
what I'm about to going
since the Pittsburgh Steelers oh this is
like [ __ ] is real life like in that
movie man I was just like cause it's
like wow like you know I haven't made it
but like I'm here holy [ __ ] you know to
me like I guess I wish you know he could
have saw that that's great man yeah you
say you had a story from your yeah so
I'm talking to crazy ass story bus about
a chick where was funny you see though
trouble I don't want to see I don't want
to hear any [ __ ] about Orlando Brown
Junior's sideline for some weird illness
and it's all their podcast you say bro
hometown kid so like that's why when I
finished the Towson yeah yeah huge dog
or like that house is he's so good even
for when I was a kid they when I went it
was called Towson State it's now tossin
University yeah it was a state school
when I was still there they got like
30,000 students now so greatly [ __ ] Wow
yeah but um bucks I met this chick right
28 [ __ ] ever bro I just got there you
know what I mean like so you got all the
highbrow around my name and everything
so I had met this chick and so she had
like hit me up I'm like uh maybe like on
a weekend like hey my parents is left
you could come over I'm like my friends
know what the deal is you know obviously
like she's like a little bit older to me
it's so so so some menus just like funny
bro see what some
I get over there start to you by each me
of the boudoir and everything is like
it's like somewhere in the country
pro-life between owings mills $1,000
black it's like you know is also those
neighborhood come with us come to grab
and go through the side gate and one her
friends guy is there right so this guy
without accent [ __ ] like you know he's
no fooling
what's going on robot some way okay cool
so like you know she had you know
streaking a little bit friend have been
drinking the guy have been drinking
they were drinking like Bakr so like
that Red Bull so they're like all
excited turnt up is [ __ ] nobody's like
Polizzi or anything
hey so Doug so literally the girls get
up they go hey I'm gonna go refill our
drinks you know but you guys wonder you
think I said nom he said yeah I'll check
another so so [ __ ] girls walk off they
close the door he looks at me and he
goes what's going on man I'm such a such
bro I said where would a [ __ ] single
mana
he goes hey these [ __ ] don't know but
um yeah you know the one on tinder girl
she's [ __ ] higher I'm just here to do
my thing in that city anyway like I said
they're coming back yeah yeah okay even
right
I go to the house do my thing a bucket
downstairs downstairs chilly either girl
I know
it literally yeah I don't know where he
just went down he comes running
downstairs just in this [ __ ] like
finished t-shirt its drawers and like
one pant leg on he looks over he goes so
I'm scared as [ __ ] in this moment it's
funny now I was scared because you see
it's so yes I'm like oh [ __ ] like
nervously [ __ ] only [ __ ] black guy
here like she was scarier and so the
girl comes downstairs and she's got
tears in her eyes and [ __ ] I'm like man
what do you do what do you do see those
know everything was that everything was
consensual I'm just he he asked me if I
was on birth control where we were
[ __ ] and he just and I so no he just
girls crying - she's like but it happens
all the time but what are your measure
[ __ ] that she had in my rookie year
with him you've been there for two
months of using a fake accent or any of
that [ __ ] man you got a habit - Sheree
over there man thank you so much man
this has been so much fun you're welcome
on here anytime I can't wait to get you
in the studio I can't wait to see it
when I come back hopefully you guys are
playing I can't wait to sit at home and
scream I can't wait to see the seven
second
lady got to put on these games to hear
you all out there talking [ __ ] cuz the
whole world is gonna hear everything you
guys say with nobody in the stands
good luck I've been following the draft
man we got with Queen I mean man we on
pay I know everything's paper and
everything is if you stay healthy but
man we get we got to look and we're
looking good we got the makings of a
dynasty right now and I think yeah man
this is gonna be a fun time watching you
[ __ ] mall people dude and any Ravens
any Ravens see this and want to come on
they're welcome to come on we'll zoom
with them from here man they can all
come on and tell their honeydew stories
but you got the one man this it's I'm
such a fan of you and your story and how
this is going for you it is seriously
storybook stuff and thank you for coming
on here and sharing it with me for real
[Music]
Ryan Sickler on all social media Ryan
Sickler calm talk to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]